when you're logging a message in your
app you need to determine what log level
it should be displayed at we're both
logs should never be compiled into your
app except during development debug logs
are compiled in but they're stripped out
at runtime error warned and info logs
are all kept and this is what the
logging API looks like the first
parameter is the log tag which can be
any string that you want to identify the
log message it's good practice to define
the log tag as a constant in your class
usually it's the name of your class or
the app the second parameter is the
actual log message if we go back to
monitor we can see that this is the log
tag column and this is where the log
messages if you click on this drop down
here you can filter the logs by log
level for example you can click on air
to see all the error messages if you
click on warn you'll see all the warning
messages as well as anything more severe
than that the same goes for the other
levels and verbose means that you can
see all the logs at all log levels as a
pro tip you should avoid log spam for
your sake and the sake of other
developers the log buffer could fill up
and important error messages that you
really need to see will either roll off
the logs or it will get lost in the sea
of unimportant log messages